Rebekah Bastian,
thank you for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm good. Thanks for having me.
You're calling from Seattle, right?
That's right.
Oh, wonderful. Wonderful.
So, I can't wait to hear
about your journey
all the way from your college years,
to becoming a VP at Zillow
after 15 years of being there,
both of product and community.
And I'd love to understand
how the two things are turned to one,
because both of them
seem so crucial today.
Especially as community people,
we have been talking
about building a community
within culture, within companies
for so long.
So, I'd love to hear about this journey
all the way to writing a book,
Blaze Your Own Trail,
and to founding a company.
Way too much to go over in 20 minutes,
but we'll try.
Rebekah, take me back
to your college days.
Because you actually have
a pretty interesting story
starting from your college days.
So, I think I went to five colleges total.
Wow.
Yeah. The first one was
a small liberal arts school in high school,
and I actually failed out of that.
And I went for music.
And just wasn't feeling it at the time.
I guess, I couldn't get my act together.
And then after that,
I moved up to Seattle with an ex-boyfriend
and after working for the year,
ended up enrolling
in the community college.
I change a couple of different colleges here
and then transferred into
University of Washington for undergrad.
I did mechanical engineering
and then ultimately ended up
also getting my masters
in mechanical engineering
from UC Berkeley.
So, a lot of educational transfers.
Right. So, on one hand you're saying
an entrepreneur and a published author,
a VP at Zillow, one of the most
well respected companies in startups
in the United States and the world.
Going to five different colleges
and failing out of the first one.
What was that about?
What happened there?
Well, you know, I think
it's all part of the winding path.
That's something that
I've certainly lived my whole life
and it hasn't been linear.
And it hasn't always been intentional,
even you know where I ended up.
But that's what I think
is important to talk about.
And I think when you dig deeper,
a lot of people that you might think
are in successful places in their lives,
it turns out that it's not always linear.
And I think that
being authentic about that
is like so many times when we're
in one of those rough patches
or screwing something up
or something's not good,
we take a look around and we see
what seems like a bunch of really
polished end results.
We can feel like we're getting it wrong
because of that whining.
So, it's one of the things
I've tried to do
in the conversations I have
and now what we're building with OwnTrail
is really embracing that winding journey.
Because it's not wrong. It leads to
some really interesting places.
Amazing. Okay.
So, before we go on to this winding path,
non-linear career pathways
and overall mentorship within OwnTrail,
I'd love to talk a little bit
about your experience with Zillow.
Zillow, it's one of my favorite companies.
I mean, I loved the transition
that's happened.
And back at Stanford,
I actually spent quite a meaningful time
with some of the machine learning teams
to understand a little bit better
about this estimate
and what's happening there.
But I'd love to hear
what was it like spending 15 years
at a fast growing company,
going to be a VP of product
and VP of community?
So, talk to me about the whole experience,
but then also these two positions
that you held.
Yeah, I mean, so the answer is super fun.
I was one of the first employees
as a stealth startup when I started there.
And which is exciting in and of itself,
looking back at that again now
in a different path.
We grew in some really meaningful ways.
Also not totally but we tried somethings.
Made some different turns
in what we were building and how.
But a lot of it was just,
we had guiding in the beginning
in a really meaningful space
to be working in around housing.
And it was really fun
to grow with the company.
And when I started there,
I went as program manager
for a couple of few years before that,
but I was still pretty junior
in my career.
And so I started as,
pretty junior program manager.
And then kept saying yes to things
and raising my hand and trying new things.
And working on a lot of different areas
of the product.
And starting initiatives and groove
into the VP of product role
and loved that.
It was really fun.
But then, what I ended up doing
after a while and all the time
I started taking on
just a lot of side projects
that were really aligned
with what I was passionate about.
So, that was really thinking about
how we create social impact
in the people building
and how we create more diversity
in our tech work.
And how we have this great culture
from the beginning organically.
And how do we foster that
as we really grow into a bigger company.
What are some of the biggest memories
that you've had?
If you look at those 15 years,
some of those like the big aha moments
or highlights that you've had
within this incredible startup.
Well, I think the biggest thing
is the friendships.
I ended up with just one friends there
and really incredible people
that I have the honor of working with.
The mobile apps are really cool
that we took on as a side project
when the iPhone first came out.
And we worked with some developers
on what would be Zillow's first mobile app
and we just did it on the side
for about a year.
And It really took off.
And ultimately I ended up
getting to be the first product manager
for our mobile initiatives.
And really leading a lot of that.
And that was really exciting.
And then, yes,
starting the community culture team
was really exciting.
Because that was a brand new team
and a new initiative as well.
That was really all of my passion
into an entire new area of my career.
So, what does entail the role of the VP
of the culture and community?
So, the way that, basically,
I created this vision
for what that team would look like
and was able to hire
[--] around it.
And the vision was really
it had equity and belonging at its core.
So, from the ground up,
it was really about creating
equitable opportunities
and just like as if they belong
in the workplace.
And from there, layering on.
Like the ways that we culturally engage
with each other and in our communities.
From there, really thinking about
how we can be leveraging
people's unique skills and passions
to solve bigger social issues
for our business and products.
So, there's a little bit distractions
based on my background and skills.
But it was really
just incredible learning curve,
incredible opportunity
to make a difference
in the organization.
And I was able to hire an amazing team
that I really learned a lot from.
So, the idea was that
as VP of culture and community,
this was internal within Zillow,
how do you foster
creative collaboration within Zillow.
So, what are some insights
can you share with me as an entrepreneur,
or my friends who are watching this,
about creating a sustainable
and healthy culture
within a diverse community?
And obviously today and throughout 2020,
this whole notion of diversity
and acceptance and culture
has been so monumental
to all of our lives and for everyone here.
So, what are some things that you learned
throughout these years at Zillow
that I can take on with me?
A lot of our philosophy behind
how we build and structure this,
none of this work is something
that can be carried out
and done by a single team
or by a few people.
It really need to be part
of the company's culture.
And so, we're really focused
on creating pathways
for engagement for employees.
So, it's really saying like,
fortunately we didn't have the problem
and we get people excited about this work.
Enthusiastic employee base
who really wanted to do the right thing.
That was part of our core values
and people really believe that.
And so, it was more about
like in the past, for people to use
their unique skills and their passions.
And get involved in the way
that feels right to them
in order to keep everything
from just everyone learning how to find
the equity lines to the business
that they're doing.
To get involved with
leading our finished works
or culture committees.
Or working on social impact products.
Or all these different pathways
for people to do that.
And I think that's a methodology
that probably applies
to different companies.
But also a lot of
different community efforts.
And any time you have
a group of people that change,
then it's about creating those pathways
to do so in a way
that really brings people together
to create that change.
Wonderful. Okay.
So, you go and you write your own book.
And it's a different type of book, right?
It's not just starting in page one
and finishing on the last page
and reading through the whole thing.
It kind of jump around.
Talk to me a little bit about this book
and how that inspired you to then create
your own venture, own trail.
Yeah. So, the book,
Blaze Your Own Trail,
it's an interactive exploration
of women's life paths.
And so, it uses the
you can choose your own journey format,
which is to choose
your own adventure books.
And which means that you, the reader,
are the person going through the story.
And you make a decision
at the end of each chapter,
and it gets you to the next.
So, essentially the whole table
of contents is the stake decision tree.
And there's all these different pathways,
there's 19 different endings.
19?
Yeah.
19 different endings to a book?
I have to say that I just finished
writing a book myself
that will be published
hopefully next week or the week after.
And I could barely think of one ending.
So, I can't even imagine
what it's like to think of a 19.
And it's a non-fiction,
so it should have been pretty easy.
Well, congrats on finishing the book.
That's super exciting.
Yeah, I think coming from that,
that product manager happened.
I think, thinking [--]
is kind of natural.
It's great.
But yeah, it's really fun.
It's really, it's trying to create
the experience
of different decisions we make
[--] as women.
And it leaves a lot of data
into it as well.
So, it is this fictional plot line.
But with data you're really creating
that sense of solidarity,
I think that might feel
like they're less common
because they don't
get talked about as much.
But in fact, there's some
really shared experiences in there.
And it create a solidarity of knowing
that we're all going through
a lot of similar things and that,
while oftentimes
the outcomes of our decisions
aren't what we necessarily thought
we wanted, we can be okay.
And we can find our happiness through
all the different twists and turns.
So, how long did this whole process take
from this idea of the
Blaze Your Own Trail,
until the day that it got published?
So, I wrote the first draft
in about five months.
And around the time,
shortly before I was finishing
the first draft,
is when I signed a contract
with my publisher.
And they were amazing.
I had my editor there
and it was really incredible
and the whole team was really incredible.
So, I had a really
positive experience with that.
So, [--] it came out,
was a year.
Now, during that year,
it's for all the different editing
and rewriting stuff.
And then there was a waiting period
and the period basically,
when OwnTrail is born.
I started thinking about
how I might create
what I thought would be
a book launch website.
Maybe something else,
trails that different women have place.
But it ended up really
taking on a life of its own
pretty quickly.
And we really found some important thing
and some big ideas for solving them
around what mentorship
has traditionally looked like.
And what it could look like
if we were able to scale it.
I and countless other women
get asked to go to coffee,
and share what our journey has been
by young women who really want
to hear those experiences and get advice.
And it just it doesn't scale.
We can't say yes to everybody.
And oftentimes we as women,
and especially women who hold
different multiple identities,
don't always have people
in our immediate purview
that look like us.
And that can be really valuable to see.
And so, what we're doing
is really creating a scalable platform
that is an aggregate
of what we call micro acts of mentorship.
Which is women
sharing the trail basically,
as they [--]
milestone's and recombining
all of those trails together
to be both this really
rich content stories, essentially,
but it's also structured by data.
So, we're essentially going to be
building out this huge neural network
of life paths that can be used
to really answer the question.
Provide the guidance and inspiration
that women are looking for
when they say
they either want to mentor
or want to be a mentor.
Wow. Okay.
So, I have to say first,
that reflecting back on this idea
of decision making trees and sometimes,
this fear of making certain decisions
and the different outcomes that can make.
And I reflect back,
I'm a huge Broadway fan.
And there was a show that I saw
quite a few times called
If/Then with Idina Menzel.
And the whole show
was about this character who has to make
some lifelong decisions.
And the show kept going
through different realities
and showing what would have happened
had she made those different decisions.
But the bottom line of the story
was that by not making a decision
or by being fearful of making a decision,
then she was making
some of the poorest decisions
by not making them in the first place.
And she was longing for that mentorship
throughout the show.
So, all about this need
that the OwnTrail is trying to solve.
So, I'm understanding that the idea
that you creating this big network
of different pathways
that people have taken.
You're creating this
community of mentorship
where women can seek mentors
or they can offer mentorship to others.
What is the pain point
that you're out there trying to solve
that came as an inspiration
through Blaze Your Own Trail?
I mean, there's two sides of pain point.
On one side, it's like we were worrying
about our pass through life
worrying about
how we're going to get there.
We needed some people who look like us
in the places we aspire to.
And we don't always have
that access to that. And honestly,
even when you enter a relationship,
you're never going to get
everything you need
from a single person, right?
There's just so many
different facets of our lives
and different situations
that it really aggregates.
And inspiration really
is so much more powerful.
But like that, and then on the flip side
is the fact that we want to be able
the past is coming up behind us.
But the traditional ways of doing that
aren't scalable.
So, I can't say yes to every coffee.
Even when I [--].
And so, what we believe is that
traditionally,
when women say they want a mentor,
they want to be a mentor,
they're really saying,
I want to be able
to solve problems I'm experiencing.
And  75% of women we know
aren't solving these problems.
They aren't getting
the mentorship they want.
So, we at OwnTrails is really reframing
what mentorship can be
in a way that reaches all women,
where they are, when they need it.
And really both provides the [--]
of these different life paths.
But then also provides
the action and the framework
to really navigate your own life
and figure out where are you going
[--]
through the power of community.
What does that mean that 75% of women
don't have the mentorship that they need?
Well, basically from observing them.
Like are you getting as much mentorship
as you wish you were.
Or are you finding as much mentorship.
And 75% say no.
Over 75% say no to this.
And so, what your thesis is that
it's a matter of accessibility that
by building a community
of givers and takers
that are obviously each person
is playing both sides
of the market, right?
You're able to create
this accessibility network
where everybody can get the mentorship
that they're looking for.
Now, are these mentorships
specifically professionally?
So, these are professional decision making
or is this could be anything?
Like I'm thinking
of going on a maternity leave,
but I'm not really sure
how my employer is going to take it.
I mean, the thing is,
like in particularly with women,
I think our personal professional lives
are so inherently intertwined.
And platform systems and discussions
tend to be siloed into like,
this is personal versus this is professional.
And so, we're really trying
to blow that idea open.
And so, yeah, it is [--] shared are.
It's yes, it's different career obstacles
that women have navigated
and accomplishments.
There's [--]
or fertility issues.
There's mental health.
There's grieving.
There is self-doubt.
There's unhealthy relationships.
There's great relationships.
And it's really, it's the culmination
of all those milestones
that really makes up
what our real journey looks like.
And it's not the perfect linear path
that we might have expected.
I love it.
Okay, Rebekah,
so two things before we go.
First, reflecting back
on the incredible experiences you've had
going to five different colleges.
And I'm calling that
an incredible experience
that probably very few people have.
So, and I'm sure that
there's a lot to take from there as well.
All the way to being VP at Zillow
and working there for 15 years
to writing a book to your own company.
What are some really key takeaways
that I could take for myself
or for my friends as we are just starting
on our journey, right?
I mean, I'm just in college now.
So, what are some things
that I should be keeping in mind
that you would recommend for me?
I really like this framework
that I recommend sometimes to people.
It is [--]
in terms of having your eyes
on some faraway vision.
And it's really,
at any point in your life thinking about
what are the things in my life
that are giving me the most energy.
Like where are my passions,
what's fueling me,
and what am I good at.
And that's not necessarily like [--]
or the job you have.
But it's like, what are those inherent,
Sorry.
No worries.
What are those inherent life path
and where you need it.
And sometimes it's as simple
as this job description
and you apply to the job.
And sometimes where you're needed
is a little bit requires
a little more creativity.
And you have to see
that there's problems to be solved
and you're the person to solve it.
But the advice really would be
if you triangulate those three things,
your skills and your passion
and where you're needed
and use that to really guide
what you do and where you go next.
I think that it will open up
some really interesting opportunities
and experiences in your life.
I love it. Rebekah, right before we go,
I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
This is really really fantastic.
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Okay. I would say creative.
Okay.
Excited. I get excited
about a lot of ideas.
And, well, a hyphenated word, risk-taker.
Creative, excited, and risk-taker. I love it.
Rebekah, thank you very very much.
OwnTrail and Blaze Your Own Trail.
And you also have a crowdfunding campaign
that's active and I believe
it has a few days left.
Well, by the time that this gets aired,
it will already be over.
But it'll be successfully over.
And I think it's like right there, right?
It's like right there.
Yeah. We're at 95% right now.
95%.
Yeah, I would love for everyone listening
that identifies as a woman
to share your trail at owntrail.com.
And everyone [--]
the woman that you know,
that are inspiring and ask them to do so.
And it's a group effort. So, yeah.
I love it.
Rebekah, thank you very very much.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you. You too.
Thanks for having me.
Thank you.